saw a tweet from you a little while ago
what's the story then she had gotten all
of her friends from high school to quit
their jobs to start this next business
with us Christmas so you find out that
we're not gonna get the money and it was
starting 48 hours later for that model
to work we were going to spend 3 300 a
day on Advertising hotels airfare rental
cars per diems for food for all of these
sales guys you fly out to these
locations and then do the launches that
we were doing successfully it was at
that moment where I said I have a
hundred thousand dollar limit on this
credit card which I still had from my
gym that the AmEx hadn't canceled yet
I'm at her parents house sleeping in
their room because we couldn't afford
anything and at this moment it's like
okay this could go horribly wrong I'm
gonna be going into debt at 3 300 a day
I respect you if you want to dip out
like I we're cool and so that was when
she said she would Tuesday with me and
so for me that was a big moment she was
willing to hang with me which was going
to be hard and I knew that where I
wanted to go is not going to be home
water I knew I needed somebody who
wanted to be next to me and would want
to weather those storms I mean for us to
get you know married after that both of
us were like yeah I think we should get
married